okay we're going to get started here in
just a few minutes as soon as my clerk
comes in and we this is going to be a
full committee work session so hang on
please
e
e good morning everyone time to start
welcome to the Tuesday March 4th meeting
of science technology and energy we will
begin today as usual by all rising and
joining representative Matson as she
allegiance to of the United States of
okay so we're here for a work session
this morning on five
bills that we will be holding an
executive session on after lunch so
we're going to start with
hr5 because we have that amendment in
hand and while the committee discusses
that amendment I will track down the
Amendments for three other bills so that
we can discuss those as
well so let's start by talking about
amendment
number
0679 H to
hr15 and I will ask representative McGee
to discuss this amendment with us thank
you Mr chair yes um I had the dubious
honor of making a comment that perhaps
we should have a few whereases at the
front of the bill to help let our
Congressional folks understand the
motivation for us asking them to
intercede with the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission and so I was
tasked with coming up with what those
wear asses would contain so starting on
um
line three uh it says whereas it is
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
practice to accept new and upgrad graded
transmission costs via a presumption of
prudence without a detailed revenue of
individual project costs and whereas
consumer utility costs are increasingly
burdensome and warrant detailed scrutiny
of large-scale Utility Systems
Investments to protect consumers and and
then it goes on to the language that was
uh in the bill to begin with the other
two things we did was we made the edit
um in the sections of the bill that had
the word Justified and cut them back to
say just and reasonable which was the
it very good representative anyone have
amendment representative
Harrington yeah first I want to thank uh
represent McGee for doing this it's it's
an definitely an improvement over what I
had had out there so I appreciate your
work I think it's very good but guess
the only com I had re run done a uh
Amendment too which I'm going to try to
cancel now if I can figure out I can
know how to send demand how to cancel
that's a different story with o s but
anyways the only thing I would see in
this that may be of the minor minor
issue is at the beginning of it in sence
three where you say whereas it is the
federal regulatory Energy Regulatory
Commission practice and
then you wait until we okay well you do
put it in another spot where you
abbreviate the firk I didn't see it in
the other spot okay so forget that it's
okay you just didn't do it in the first
one you did it on line 13 you put it so
that's as long as it's people understand
that FK is is is the FC so this looks
fine any other comments representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas yes thank you um
I've just never seen it before so could
somebody explain to me why the New
Hampshire State librarian is included in
yes that's essentially for archival
purposes virtually everything that H
goes through the legislature ends up in
the State library or the state archives
one or the other but doesn't it end up
there
automatically I mean
why don't they archive all legal
documents I suspect that they do but
this is added to the legislation just uh
as an assurance
that it happens okay I me I don't
necessarily have a problem with it I
just have never seen it before pretty
standard boiler plate for this kind of
hr15
on I will now pass out an amendment for
HB
221 and we will discuss
221 this is a work
session relative to assessment of cost
eff cost effectiveness of the system
benefits
do
do you guys have enough that
okay all right does everybody have a
amendment
the the amendment replaces the bill
bill and the first part of the amendment
starting on line8 going all the way down
Bill the amendment adds a new section
starting on line
26 that runs
through
um line 15 on page
two and then the amendment also adds the
text on line 16 and 17 on page
two and the reason for this amendment
starting on page one at line 26 is that
most of this text is now
Obsolete and so it has been struck from
and then at the very end
of the paragraph on page three after the
strikeout on lines 14 and
15 the word rate payer is replaced with
the word
customer uh in that sentence so it reads
rate it used to read rate payer savings
savings and so that's what the amendment
does and I'm open to questions and
amendment representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um I'm intrigued um
about replacing rape hair with customer
what what do you see as the difference
okay that was a suggestion made by the
Commission there was a typo corrected
tour in that sentence also on line 14
where the word asure is been in placed
replaced by the word
insure did they give you any I I can't
remember I can look through my notes did
they give you any justification for
customer I don't recall from their from
their text I don't have it right in
front of me what their reason for
replacing rate paay with customer was to
be honest with you okay excuse me chair
yes rep representative CL yes uh could
it have to do with line first page line
suggestion so uh representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman um so I I kind of
like to take us back to the purpose of
the bill um it it appears that the major
intent of the bill is to allow the
Public Utilities Commission to
have uh latitude to move away from using
the granite state test and the
identified testing metrics metrics that
we um kind of painstakingly put in place
as a state um and uh you know to give
them latit basically to come to maybe
different results than what the granite
state test um and the the current mode
of
reviewing um the New Hampshire saves
trienal plans uh was designed to do so
I'm wondering whether we should be
discussing at all uh whether those
needed because the the cost
Effectiveness piece is what led us to
state so who who is saying that it isn't
adequate representative Harrington filed
this bill okay uh
representative sure I uh I work with the
uh pu on this they felt as though that
there's nothing specifically wrong with
the granted state test but it's getting
old it was developed some time ago and
there we shouldn't hold people's to
something that old and instead allowing
them to come up with a different method
if it's seemed to be a better method and
as it says additional tests developed
through an adjudicative process and
approve them by order prior to
commencement of any trienal udit or
period beginning with the program year
2027 so that if there was going to be a
change this would have to be an
adjudicated process in front of the Pu
where everybody would get to come in and
put their two cents worth in as to why
you should make the change why you
shouldn't make the change why you should
make this additional change and then
that would be adjudicated uh it's it's
just a matter of allowing flexibility to
improve the process and who would make
the decision if that the adjudicated
process is in the control of the Public
Utilities Commission is that correct
correct okay so it's it's of by and for
the Pu but I I guess there would there
was never really I in the hearings I
didn't
hear an adequate argument that the you
know many of us are old right we're not
obsolete we get better with age so it
doesn't mean just because something's
been around for a while doesn't mean it
uh it requires renovation what what I
didn't hear was what they were trying to
solve for in terms of identifying cost
Effectiveness right that's the goal is
to make sure that the plans that are
presented are cost effective but there's
no delineation of what cost effective is
is it is it three times return four
times return 10 times return who who
decides that if you pass this bill what
you do is you put it back in the hands
of the public utilities commission who
all of us had to override when they
found a trienal plan that didn't work
brought in front of them that everyone
else uh that was involved in development
of that plan agreed was good for the
State of New Hampshire so I'm just
trying to figure out whether we're
making things worse by passing this bill
that was requested by the Public
Utilities Commission so that the Public
Utilities Commission has
more uh ability to upend future plans
so one of the uh reasons for this
amendment and this bill in general is
that when we did pass HB
541 back in 2000 I think it
was
2022 when we did pass that bill um there
was an extensive amendment that went
with it
that put into statute the procedure that
we wanted the you Public Utilities
Commission to follow in order to deal
with Energy Efficiency and the system
benefits charge going
forward and that fairly large and
complex administrative change Amendment
change I should say included language
that restricted the Public Utilities
Commission to only looking at and
evaluating changes to the program
from one trianium to the next rather
than being able to evaluate the
entire three-year trianium plan so this
amendment is designed
to address that
oversight that was put into statute I
believe
unintentionally back in 2022 I know I
worked on that Amendment and I was
unaware that that restriction had been
added to the legislation and it was not
something that I would have approved at
the time had I realized it Mr chairman
is that is that related to the 97%
versus 3% that they've brought up yes is
that what you're talking about yes okay
and and I think that's a feature not a
bug and that that's why I'm that's why
I'm bringing it up here because I think
I think that 549 actually did what you
and others you know what we intended
which was
to further Define the Contours of the
program so that there wouldn't be an
attempt to U overspend in terms of
taking advantage of the rate payers so
it put Contours around it and said this
is how it will go forward this is how it
will grow so it was it was very
deliberate um and the whole idea was to
maintain stability in that program for
all of the stakeholders that are
involved including small weatherization
businesses I mean we were both there for
that um so I guess what I'm asking is is
the granite state test still
supports um what was originally
envisioned for a review by the Public
Utilities Commission and it almost seems
as though the Public Utilities
Commission is trying to figure out some
way
to um have a way to
say that changes to the program are
unwarranted it you know it just it
doesn't seem like it's based on uh
finding something that's wrong with the
granite state test that needs to be
fixed we didn't get any specifics on
that we just got please give us the
ability to do something else if we if we
feel that that's appropriate and um they
didn't really give us anything
compelling about what they thought they
would need to do so I I'm inclined not
to support it because I don't think they
ever said what was wrong with the
granite state test the granite state
test they testified
here didn't take certain costs into uh
account but it also didn't take certain
benefits into account and it was
specifically designed that way to be an
adequate test that would give them uh a
cost benefit evaluation that was
reasonable and so what we didn't get was
what are you pointing to that needs to
be fixed and what are you pointing to
that you think would be better in terms
of getting us to a place where we can
assign reasonable or do you just want to
be able to say what's reasonable and
what isn't and I I think it's too
arbitrary I think they should do more
work if they want us to change the
law so the not of the issue here is that
if we're going to spend 70 to 80 million
doar of rate payer money on a yearly
basis to implement Energy Efficiency
programs how do we know that we're
getting the best value for that every
dollar of that 70 to8
million
expense and the Public Utilities
Commission has told us that based on the
way the legislation is written
today they have no ability to
determine if all those millions of
dollars are being spent in the best
manner possible so that rate payers can
get a maximum return for their
investment these changes are designed to
allow the Public Utilities Commission to
do a full and thorough analysis and
oversight of these programs every three
years which I think is what we intended
when we created the legislation back in
2022 thank you I have one more thing I'd
say on that just if you go ahead that um
when I first started paying attention uh
to the trianal plans it was the
utilities that were providing us with um
an a report on the return on investment
um specifically related to the return on
investment for a specific prior
three-year plan and so the information
is available whether people believe it
or like it um that it was not a question
of us not having anything to assess and
so um it's not a black box the the
program was extremely well-run it was
award-winning it still is I guess I
don't know but I know that I've I
certainly have still at home three-year
um reports from eversource and um the
other utilities who used to contribute
via the easy board um I we have reports
because they were required statutorily
to provide those reports that let us
know the cost benefit analysis the last
one I reviewed was $3.8 for every dollar
spent so it was a three plus return on
investment and again I don't know what
the state thinks is sufficient but once
you spend money to save energy on a
building then you're lowering demand
which lowers the cost of the system for
everyone which is the reason that we're
doing demand side investment so I I
still don't understand how this bill
advances anything except allows more of
a fishing Expedition right so there's
97% that isn't up for review you're just
looking at
changes um and the Pu is saying no we
want to throw all of it up in the air
and we have to figure out do we want
them to throw it up in the air because I
don't I don't think that that's a good
use of anyone's time I there's never
been a question that the utilities were
running the New Hampshire saves program
well and every constituent that I've
ever talked to in my community
Republican and Democrat has said they
they really like that program and uh
hurt well we all know that we have great
Utilities in this in this state well-run
utilities that serve us
well but the perennial question that the
Public Utilities Commission is forced to
ask is do we just trust the
utilities do we just let them do what
they want because they assure us that
what they're
doing meets their own cost benefit test
or should we take a look at what they're
doing and make try to make a judgment
about whether they in fact are doing the
best that they can for the rate payer
and the dollars that are being invested
on his or her behalf so I think that's
what we're saying here if we're going to
look
at utility rates on a regular basis with
a skeptical uh eye or a critical eye
shouldn't we look at everything
utilities do with a skeptical or
critical eye and that's what this bill
and this amendment seeks to do with
regard to the Energy Efficiency programs
representative
rainolds thank you Mr chairman
um I
share uh my ranking members concern if
not objection to the basically to the
premise of this bill uh I wasn't of
course part of you know what went on
back in
2022 but I've heard plenty about it
heard it
discussed uh but I was uh this very this
very subject matter uh
was about the first 10 years of my
professional experience um in the in the
Energy Efficiency field Energy
Efficiency
measures cost
Effectiveness all that stuff I work for
the nonprofit Northeast Energy
Efficiency Partnerships that was
contracted on behalf of all the
utilities in New England to design uh
consistent programs design programs uh
so that all of that program
design um planning and coordinate could
be done efficiently across States so
that every state didn't have to every
utility in every state didn't have to
invent their own programs and Implement
their own programs and do all the
science and Analysis behind it anyway um
all of that stuff is pretty well
established you know Energy Efficiency
programs run by utilities across the
country have been in place for you know
30 years um and so you know energy
conservation measures and payback
analysis uh it's kind of a it's kind of
a science and expertise and it doesn't
change you know year to year every three
years uh
but
um the testimony that we heard yesterday
in this room from the consumer
Advocate
about you know the um anyway that whole
the testimony from from Don cre
yesterday uh that concerned partly the
dynamic between the Pu and the our own
Department of energy uh the Pu refusing
to stay in its Lane as no longer the
policy making
executive branch uh
entity
uh um and the lack of deference that the
Pu has showed to parties who bring a
settlement agreement to the Pu for
approval which of course was the whole
controversy three years ago with the
Energy Efficiency programs they were
brought you know by the utilities by the
consumer Advocate by the
interveners another set of here's the
next three-year
um set of of Energy Efficiency programs
and the Pu suddenly decided it had bet
knew more
and and and just blew it
up you know
and that should all that what we heard
yesterday should be ringing in our ears
when we're thinking about this because I
see this bill as the Public Utilities
Commission trying to again get get out
of its Lane and assert itself and say oh
well we suddenly have all we with our
whatever we are third remaining 13 or 15
staff suddenly have all kinds of
expertise where we're going to dig into
the the
uh analysis that has long undergirded
these programs and as representative
McGee cited they've been shown to have a
3.8 3.7 to1 doll return uh for every
dollar spent in the programs that is
rate payers customers who take advantage
of the programs experience $3.8 in in uh
Energy savings over over certain
durations you know and the to the
economy uh but that but with the the
lifetime of the measures is is so
there's like if you don't it's really
Arcane stuff but um you know every
energy conservation measure has a
duration over what time period should
the should the savings be counted and I
see that that basically um what's a foot
here is is POL people differing on
policy who want to get into it in the
name of we have more expertise and
suddenly we're going to decide that you
know those savings don't last so long
we're going to make a pol policy
decision to to not count that as
savings um and and we're going to we're
going to change this up and it it's not
necessary and it's not um
it's not valid uh there's a lot of
experience history and uh proven coste
Effectiveness that that are in these
Energy Efficiency programs that our
utilities run and that utilities across
New England across the country run uh
and it's not necessary to every three
years give our puuc the ability to start
tinkering in there and again going to
the stability of these programs that
customers not just residential
businesses Industries count on being
available
and that the businesses who are part of
that uh little part of our economy
insulation weatherization providers
which we were talking about yesterday
weatherization uh those are small
businesses and medium-sized businesses
that are involved in in the supply of
Energy Efficiency Services and measures
and you can't just have this make it
into law that well every three years we
might pull the rug out from under this
because we don't we just we we've
decided suddenly among our little staff
that um you know we know better so I I
don't like this bill at
all yeah I kind of got that
impression although I am I will say I am
kind of astounded that you feel that uh
a program as huge as this one doesn't
require any oversight that that kind of
baffles that is not that is not what I'm
saying ber plenty of oversight
thank you Mr chair so I I look at the
language in this bill and it still says
the grand state test is the primary test
with the addition of the Total Resource
test as a secondary It also says that
they the appy may consider some
modifications in the adjudicative
process it doesn't say they're going to
throw the whole thing out and we're
going to start with a new bathtub and
I don't believe that is the intent nor
is that going to be the the process that
will be follow please wait till you're
recognized to speak so uh I I do not
find this a unacceptable bill I think
it's a a good opportunity to allow the
commission to use new
analysis as it may be
appropriate representative Harrington
yeah a couple of quick things one thing
that was said earlier which which I
totally don't agree with because I don't
think it's correct is that every
megawatt we save saves money for
everybody if you look at the demand
curve it's basically pretty flat only
during peak times you can cut a
substantial number of uh megawatts from
demand and it has no effect at lowering
rates because that curve is very very
flat until it gets to the peak times
when it then every megawatt really
really makes a difference uh the second
thing I want to make and this concept
somehow that because a small business is
getting subsidies through rate payers to
install whe whatever they were
installing weather stripping uh
insulation whatever that sometime that
gives them a permanent rate right to
collect that money forever just isn't
correct they're getting money because of
a government edict the government
obviously has the ability to take that
away at any time they they don't grant
them any right when they get that and in
third this they're talking about the Pu
as if they have nothing to do with this
this is part of setting rates the Pu is
the one who sets the rates they
determine what the utility is going to
get uh for a rate and the effectiveness
of these programs is part of that rate
so obviously they're the person who
should be involved in doing it and again
there's nothing in here that says they
have to change anything it simply gives
them the flexibility to open an
adjudicative proceeding and to look at
something that at this case is going to
be five six seven years old and see if
things changed maybe the way we're
producing energy in 2028 or 2030 might
be different such that these uh Energy
Efficiency methods need to change I
don't know but I don't want to lock the
uh the hands of the Pu to even consider
that and again this is part of rates
because the rate payers are paying for
the Energy Efficiency cost so setting
that how those works is part of setting
rates and that's the purview of the Pu
representative Corman has a comment
thank
you
um so um chairman Vose asked
commissioner chatt chatab I gu I have
trouble saying it um asked him
uh that the the granted state test
doesn't capture all the costs the Total
Resource test doesn't capture all the
benefits together do they capture all
the cost and benefits and the answer was
no
um and and the commissioner said that
the bill would be a step in the right
direction then I asked all right if we
need a new test who creates the test and
the commissioner's answer would was that
it would be part of a pu
docket so one possible way to go here
would be to have the Pu open a docket
and look for a new test but that the
legislature would have to approve this
new test just like the legislature
approved the granite state test give the
Pu the flexibility if you really want to
try to come up with a new test go for it
but you don't get to actually use it
it interesting idea further comments on
this
amendment uh representative
Kaplan yeah I mean I think that that's a
a possible solution what representative
Corman just mentioned I just fear that
we we've we went through a similar
docket not too long ago and at the end
of the day who's going to pay for that
docket you know that that's just money
what all this is about is money and
we're going to be spending money to
develop a new
test you know and as as we heard here
just recently I mean the grand state
test is an adequate test it considers
some of the costs and some of the
benefits it doesn't provide a total
picture so opening up that can of worms
again that's a debate that can go on
forever you know so I mean we have an
adequate test as it is and do we want to
just go down that road again I'm not
spending okay any further comment
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
yeah I'd just like to draw attention to
the fact that we have a couple of people
in the audience who are actually
responsible for these uh the New
Hampshire saves program for their
organizations and people who were
formerly on the Energy Efficiency and
sustainable energy board the easy board
um these are the folks that go uh in
front of the Public Utilities Commission
with those plans and justify them and
help put together reports um basically
you know they're required to
justify uh the plans so it's not like
the Pu doesn't already have oversight
and information from people who have
subject matter expertise
the that's what they are that's their
job their job is Energy Efficiency
programs in the state of New Hampshire
and making sure that the Public
Utilities Commission has what it needs
in order to okay those plans so it it's
a lot of times when we talk about bills
where people don't have
any uh firsthand knowledge everyone just
gets in their head what how they think
this thing occurs um there isn't
actually U that I'm aware of a problem
here that is in need of solving in terms
of the stakeholders but it sounds like
the Public Utilities Commission is
looking for some kind of definition that
um as representative Kaplan said the
debate could go on a very long time as
to what is the correct thing to be
looking at um it took a really long time
to get everyone to agree that the
granite state test was an adequate test
so so why why are we circling um I would
not be in of this bill because what it
does is it gives an open-ended process
to a group of um you know appointed
folks who do not have subject matter
expertise in this particular thing I
mean I know that the most vocal person
on the Public Utilities Commission I
listened to his appointment in front of
the executive councel he had no energy
experience at all when he was hired to
that job and that can happen you can be
appointed for other other things that
you're good at and finance is one of the
things he was good at um
but to be acquiescing as a legislature
to a bill that is vague from someone who
does not have subject matter expertise
who is telling us give me the ability to
question the people who do know what
they're doing because I don't know if
they know what they're doing I think
we're we're creating a problem if we put
if we put this bill forward and I do I
am um verbose
I am a chatty Kathy but I don't normally
proze like this and this is a small Bill
really but I really don't think it's a
good bill and um and I I hope that
you'll consider the fact that what it
does is it opens a door to give the
Public Utilities Commission the ability
to say yes or no to anything that comes
before them and to open an adjudicative
proceeding where they are the end all of
the decision
and it doesn't it hasn't provided us
with any more information about what
we're enabling so it isn't it just isn't
a good bill from that standpoint and I
idea okay we have two other bills we
need to discuss representative Swanson
thank you so in summary of the things
that I've heard do we get close enough
to good enough With The Changes suggest
with a change suggested by
representative Corman I mean is that in
feasibility I guess that would be a
discussion that uh individual caucuses
would have but that's not what's on the
moment all right let's talk about a
here so the next bill we want want to
discuss
is House Bill
FN that's a bill that is designed to
allow for off-grid electricity providers
in New
Hampshire
and I have a relatively small Amendment
here that basically just cleans up a
couple of ambiguities in the
original legislation so let's pass that
out
changes while that's happening I'll
remind everybody that this is enabling
legislation and all it does is Define
what an off-grid electricity provider is
and in a moment we'll discover what it
it is
not
and also defines that or or state
that such an off-grid electricity
provider would essentially be
unregulated not subject to uh regulation
but there will be a few minor exceptions
to
that so does everyone have a copy of the
amendment at this
point okay so here are the changes
online
nine after the word boundaries there is
a new sentence added off-grid
Utilities that would probably seem
obvious
but it was suggested to me that stating
that explicitly in the legislation is a
good
idea the next change is down on line 14
where it says um shall be exempt from
previously that
said from this title and it was
suggested that we might want to spell
out what this title is so it now says
RSA title
34 which is the title in our r rsas that
encompasses
all energy regulation
the next change is on line
15 after the word regulations I added a
comma and
the phrase such as Municipal and state
highway safety regulations and another
comma that was to indicate that while
these facilities would be basically
unregulated by energy law they're not
exempt from um other laws that apply
particularly health and safety
laws and then the final change is on
line 20 and once again it just
changes
U
read provisions of this title to read
provisions of RSA title
34 so those are the changes to the that
the amendment makes
and I'd appreciate any comments
representative rolds thank you Mr
chairman um I think appreciate the
changes I think they're good changes
um my just just just a question dealing
with uh the last one that you
mentioned um it seems to me that I mean
because you called out specifically
Municipal and state highway safety
regulations
um and you do say they shall remain
subject to all other applicable laws and
regulations so I guess things like fire
codes uh electrical codes all that I
guess would fall under that it seems uh
enormously significant if if a town had
you know giant uh electricity generator
and
Battery that um towns would be very
concerned
um so I guess it's it's in there all
other applicable laws and regulations
maybe it's NE codes to mention codes um
maybe it's
assumed okay thanks you're welcome rep
uh representative Harrington yeah I just
had a question because I'm looking back
up my notes from this
and on line nine when it says does not
cross state boundaries I'm not even sure
what that means do it mean State
boundaries like the boundary between New
Hampshire in Vermont or is it the
boundary between property that's not
owned by the state and property that is
owned by the state so that to me is not
really clear and I have a note here
about no Crossing government land or
roads and I'm trying to think back if
any particular regulations kick in uh if
you putting like a transmission line
across a um a government-owned road or
highway I think that automatically kicks
into some additional regulation it may
even get the site evaluation Committee
involved and I just wonder if we have to
address that in this
bill the amendment actually addresses
that first off the original bill and the
amendment specifically mentions RSA 162
which is the site evaluation or the
sighting Bill the sighting
statute and the phrase that I added such
as Municipal and state highway safety
regulations
would cover the issue that you just
raised about a transmission line
crossing a highway either a municipal or
State Highway they would have
to abide by any
regulations regarding that
Crossing and with regard to cross state
boundaries I think that that's fairly
standard um terminology to
indicate the demarcation between one
State and another state so yes we're
talking about the the state line between
New Hampshire and
Vermont further discussion
representative
McGee thank you Mr chair yeah I I just
went in to look at
34 um RSA 34 in terms of what we're
exempting um these generators from and I
I don't understand honestly I don't
understand how it would work I
understand it's intended to be enabling
legislation but it's saying that these
these folks can transmit and
distribute um and sell electricity at
retail prices to Consumers if they're
not connected but all of the rules that
are under um RSA 34 Public Utilities
they're not considered public utilities
but these are basically all the rules um
in terms of what happens if there's a
violation um you know uh if there are
false entries if there's negligence so
we're exempting folks that they can just
go do whatever they want to do and there
isn't anybody who has oversight for them
and it it says other rules apply but why
wouldn't these rules apply even though
they were designed originally for
utilities that's because only utilities
were running gas operations and electric
distribution
um why would we exempt folks from all of
these there's no reporting there's no
oversight there's no there's no way to
Corral somebody even if they're doing
illegal so this is a bill designed to
unleash
Innovation and it it was originally
called
customer regulated
energy and the reason it was called
customer regulated is because
essentially there would have to be a
contract between the provider of the
electricity and the buyer of the
electricity so the contract would be
um I'm drawing a blank on the right word
here but the contract would be the the
the thing that that controls or that
governs the relationship between the the
buyer and the seller and it would have
within
it all of the legal requirements that
one party would want to impose on the
other uh and vice versa they obviously a
contract is a negotiated document
so that's the kind of Regulation that
would be
that would happen here it would be
strictly regulated by the buyer and the
seller as long as it didn't interfere
with Municipal and state highway safety
regulations as stated in the bill and as
long as it conformed to the precepts of
our sighting statute so there is no
other NE uh regulation required here and
the reason the bill exists
is to establish that no other regulation
is required to govern this relationship
seller representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um in my notes from the
hearing I have um I I I took note of
off-grid pricing um and specifically
that Texas rates were raised during
severe weather events um and I also
wrote that this creates a situation
where customers are held
hostage um I have con I have great
concerns um about setting up these
independent
energy
generators well once again that would be
covered by the contract between the
two I know somebody um that I spoke with
about this bill raised the situation of
well what happens when
the off-grid electric electricity
provider has to shut down or maintenance
or or maybe even they have an unexpected
shutdown like a an an equipment
malfunction or something what happens
then well it's up to the contract
between the generator and the buyer to
specify in that contract what happens in
that
situation it's not up to uh regulation
to specify what happens there it's up to
the relationship between the buyer and
the seller but who oversees these
contracts I mean I assume they're legal
contracts and there is some oversight
where is
that well the only oversight that a
legal contract would be subject to would
be the oversight of the courts so if a
legal contract is challenged by one
party or the other
it could end up in
court but other than that there is no
contract representative Harrington yeah
as far as the um uh part of what happens
if the um generator goes down either
because of a planned outage or a
inadvertent outage due to equipment
failures I mean this would be clearly
spelled out in the contract it could be
a situation where in order to get a
better rate the person buying the
electricity makes a deal and says okay
if you if you go down with uh if your
capacity Factor remains at 90% or better
we'll pay this rate but if it drops
below 80% we're going to pay a lower
rate as an incentive to get them to do
that now obviously since no one
generator is going to run unless they
had multiple sources that were
independent it's not going to be 100% of
the time so then the entity consuming
the power would probably go onto the
grid and in that case they would have to
have a separate transmission system or
distribution system bringing the power
into them and they'd be subject on the
purchase of that power to the
regulations of the Pu and the uh utility
and one of which would more than likely
be a demand charge because if 90% of the
time you're consuming no electricity and
then 10% of the time you want to flip a
switch and get I don't know 2 megawatts
per hour the electric company's going to
want you to pay for that privilege and
rightly should because that's something
they're going to have to plan on so
those are two separate things that
shouldn't be put together this this is a
contract just like someone hires a
contract for um building a house or or
whatever the regulations that that apply
would be environmental regulations as
stated here that would apply to
everybody but there's nothing specific
to the contract between the generator
and the consumer as to who's how they're
going to buy the electricity what
they're going to pay for it that that's
just like every other contract it's
decided between the two individuals
signing
it representative Wendy Thomas thank you
Mr chair um as the prime sponsor of this
bill um do you envision we've had a lot
of bills about nuclear power do you
envision nuclear power uh falling under
this
agreement well it certainly could um the
idea of this bill came from as I
mentioned in my testimony on the bill
from Texas and in Texas there is a
movement to create some big AI data
centers and at least one or two of those
locations are envisioned to uh be
powered by a nuclear power plant I think
a company called Kos has contracted with
Amazon to build 235 megawatt nuclear
small Mo molten salt reactor uh nuclear
power plants to power some AI D data
centers down in Texas could that happen
here
maybe and maybe it would be an economic
did representative Harrington yeah just
just to be sure so there's no confusion
here this bill have nothing to do with
the regulation of any nuclear power
plant that would remain regulated by the
NRC it's not unregulated they would
still have to be subject to let's say
Dees in New Hampshire and the EPA if
they had a water discharge permit or an
air discharge permit uh if they were
digging holes in the ground they'd be
subject to Dees regulations on that
they're not exempt from any of this
they're just exempt from the regulations
that apply only to a public utility
that's in a generator that's over using
transmission lines there's no they not
going to be deregulated the NRC will
definitely be there Dees will definitely
be there and all the acquired permits
will have to be had and
maintained that is correct this bill
only exempts these uh off-grid
electricity providers from State
regulation not Federal Regulation and
not all state regulation though it's
just the regulation pertaining to a
generator and the utility and
transmission because they're still going
to be under the guise of like for
example Dees they're going to need water
permits air discharge permits from EPA
uh ground disturbance permits from Dees
as well digging holes as is specified in
the bill on line 16 representative
Corman thank
you I counted how many chapters are in
title uh 34 and there are 38 chapters
and it just seems like that's exempting
from a lot of law um I'm I'm I'm a bit
uncomfortable with that I'm also just
concerned about safety in
general uh when when Mr Lata testified
he talked about the concern about uh
wires Crossing
roadways and and I asked about that and
he said well you know what you do on
private property is your concern so if
it doesn't cross a roadway they're not
concerned but you know my concern is you
know maybe a fire is generated at one of
these facilities and fires have a way of
not caring about property lines and
Roads uh so I'm I'm just generally
concerned about safety here somebody
just operating a power plant unregulated
happens further
comment representative McGee yeah my
comment was similar in that I I've just
my my mind is you know that this bill is
the what could go wrong bill because
we're not
envisioning
um we're not we're not
specifying how these extra regulatory
uh generation
facilities would need to have um
some boundaries around them for for
Public Safety so the details of what
goes into the contract between the
generator and the person who's you know
hiring them to provide their uh energy
for most of the time um that part I'm
not as concerned about except that I
don't think that everyone that's
entering into that contract might know
all the things that they would need to
put in because we kind of assume that
when someone's providing electricity to
us that there are regulatory imperatives
about safety and phasing the electricity
onto the system and you know that the
wires are appropriate that that
everything is being done in a way that
is standardized and is safe to your
point and none of that applies here
right so somebody can put together
whatever they're they think is probably
the easiest way for them to get
uh to the
contract and not necessarily take some
of the safety aspects into consideration
that regulations require of other people
that are providing electricity that
concern so I can imagine that if I'm
going to buy electricity
from one of these
generators that in the contract I'm
going to make sure that I cover my own
business's safety
issues in the contract I'm not going to
just ignore safety for my my business
that would be economic suicide so the
contract is likely to be the document
that deals with a lot of these issues
that all of you have legitimately raised
nevertheless the key to this legislation
is that it is enabling legislation it
doesn't attempt to solve all the
problems that might occur from the
development of these facilities
and
uh it leaves this the solving of those
problems to
innovators to come up with unique
solutions that probably that maybe none
of us have even thought about or
envisioned so that's what the purpose
here is is representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman I happen
to be looking at RSA title 34 and uh
what I noticed is is although there's a
lot of chapters here predominantly it's
about how the state collects money and
so I don't know if this is being viewed
or argued because by eliminating title
34 that they're just some folks believe
that the state's losing the a uh um
Revenue Foundation from it so it it
authorizes non- Capal Reserve funds it
requires payments into the fund it
requires investment policies for trust
funds it defines the trustees of the
funds it requires payments from Surplus
so what I'm thinking is I don't know if
the argument for eliminating title 34 is
whether it's a safety or safety
regulation or is it more about the
collections of money from folks so they
okay further comment representative
blog thank you chair just so I
understand this
better we got two facilities one's
generating
power going to be built on a piece of
property and probably nearby another
facility is going to use that power to
uh make
something we got two empty lots of land
to put the generator and the user has to
go through all the requirements of the
state safety as you said environmental
and
everything now it's built and all so
this bill I'm getting to the question
only in my
regulates allows
one the generator to
transmit that energy to the next
property by contract of how when and
what
have a the safety should be taken care
analogy to to my mind you didn't miss
anything that's exactly what this does
yeah all right let's move on because we
have one more Bill to discuss
uh representative Harrington I'll be
quick just the other thing we really
haven't mentioned either is you're still
dealing with local building codes and
building inspectors if you're putting up
a building to put a generator in it's
going to have it get a building permit
and they going to be inspections
involved in that and if the transmission
line or whatever you want to call it
distribution line goes across a third
party's property then they're going to
say you want to build that line across
my property you're going to have to get
a building permit make sure it meets all
the all the requirements for running
electrical lines across my property and
you're going to pay me for the privilege
by the way and the same thing when it
gets to the person who's getting the
electricity in hooking that up again is
going to be required under the U you get
a building code it's going to be
inspected by the local uh people as well
so it's not it doesn't exempt them from
all sorts of rules it just says it
utility that is correct okay so there's
another amendment that we want to
consider and that's for House Bill 710 I
just handed that out does everybody have
a
copy all right so you'll recall that in
the original Bill House Bill
710 after um defining what an advanced
nuclear resource is that bill set
up a a series of changes to RSA 374
DG to allow utilities to invest in or
even own an advanced nuclear resource
similar to the way that a utility today
can invest in or own a re distributed
generation
resource and many of you had issues with
the idea that a utility could invest in
or own a nuclear power plant PL because
they're pretty
expensive so this amendment completely
removes that uh provision from the
bill that is no longer part of HB
instead what the bill does is it makes
it possible for utilities to sign
purchase power agreements with Advanced
nuclear resources and it uses the
language of RSA 374 colon
11 which was added to law two years ago
by Senate Bill 54 those of you who were
here at the time will remember that
Senate Bill 54 was designed to allow
utilities to purchase up to 20% of their
load in a PPA from a
new utility
resource and it was technology neutral
it didn't care what kind of resource it
was it just had to be a newly developed
resource so what I've done here is I've
I've modified that language to allow
for nuclear resources to
be
uh for utilities to enter into ppas with
nuclear resources the way Senate Bill 54
was originally
written basically there was a a drop
dead date of
2026 for proposals for these new ppas to
be uh signed so what I've done here is
I've
for advanced nuclear resources I've made
an ex an exception that allows them to
be developed proposals to be developed
for these ppas up until
2035 so it extends by 10 years basically
the provisions of Senate Bill 54 with
regard to Advanced nuclear
resources so that's the major change
here the other minor change is on lines
5 through nine I expanded the definition
of advanced nuclear resource just to
include many of
the the technologies that are used to
create these reactors and I also changed
the the original Bill stated that they
had a generation capacity of between 1
and 90 megawatts I've now changed that
to Z and 300 megawatts which is more in
line with the industry definition for
advanced nuclear resources so those are
the changes that I've made to
House Bill 17 I think this is a much
cleaner way to go about allowing
utilities if they're interested to
acquire some um some of their load from
nuclear resources and I'd be interested
reactions representative McGee thank you
I thought I saw other people first all
thank you um my question is about the
language that starts on line 12 on page
one it says investor own electric
distribution utilities may elect to
develop and no later than June 30th of
2025 issue a requests for proposals for
multi-year agreements for energy in
conjunction with or independent of any
attendant environmental attributes from
electric energy sources and then the
bolded language is what includes uh
nuclear resour Advanced nuclear
resources up to you know 10 years hence
so June 30th of 2035 but I don't
understand why the first
line uh limits any
other
uh any other investor
owned uh Investments or PPA
agreements that have to be done before
June of this year so
I you'll have to go back and look at the
um the debate over Senate Bill 54 that's
language directly that was added to
statute directly as a result of Senate
Bill 54 well I guess I would just
acknowledge it here in this working
meeting as maybe not great language
because it is saying that that anything
that isn't nuclear they can't enter into
it right it's it's it sounds like a
Prohibition after that date is that
right I'm just was a Prohibition before
I wrote this amendment and it's still a
Prohibition I didn't change it right and
I and I think I don't know if we have
ever asked the utilities about that but
I'm wondering if if we're writing uh an
amendment now that um extends a window
because obviously there would be quite a
bit of time needed in order to get
Advanced nuclear up and running um for a
PPA on one form of energy why would we
in the same paragraph be limiting their
ability to entertain ppas long-term ppas
on any other type of
energy I mean I think we should consider
changing that language or eliminating
that language because it does seem
unusually
restrictive I'll be honest with you I
don't remember during the debate over
Senate Bill 54 why we why we restricted
it maybe commissioner Elms from the
remember no pressure
though War the record uh Deputy
Commissioner Chris Elms from the
Department of energy and I'm going to
admit I was sending a text while we were
discussing there so I have no idea what
we're talking about but I'm happy to
answer
questions so Senate Bill 54 language was
what I gleaned but um yeah so Senate
Bill
54 said that investor-owned electric
distribution utilities can develop and
no later than June 30th of 2025 issue a
request for proposals why June 30th 2025
sure so uh Senate Bill 54 was a pretty
major change in uh in the state's view
on energy procurement and specifically
authorized these uh the potential for
power purchase agreements um if we
remember back to to the time which I I
think was two years ago uh you know we
we had experienced the the price shock
that was due in large part to the
invasion in Ukraine and I think there
was a desire from from the legislature
from the Governor from from stakeholders
to to do something to perhaps uh work on
uh looking at some you know essentially
Financial Hedges to what we were seeing
there and so the idea of a power
purchase agreement uh you know became
attractive to folks it was something
that the department at the time had uh
significant concerns uh related to
rapair impact so as we were talking
about what that bill would look like and
and uh you know the bill did recognize
that New Hampshire new England has a
building things problem to an extent uh
but but because this was sort of a novel
idea that we were looking at the idea
was that this is uh in response to a
problem that's happening now we want to
keep this limited we don't want this to
be an authority that we're just throwing
the door open to that we wanted to uh
keep it limited see what came out of it
uh as you might I don't know if it's
reflected in the amendment I'm sorry I
haven't seen it there's also some other
restrictions such as a 2 million
megawatt hour cap on what was allowed
which represents about I think it's 17
18% of New Hampshire's load and
uh you know the idea was let's see what
comes of this uh what we haven't seen
anything come of it uh thus far so sorry
that was if that was off the cuff uh
hopefully it was helpful so does that
representative McGee does that help you
um understand why there's a restriction
here um yeah I understand the history on
it I'm just wondering whether it seems
because because it basically says no
later than does that mean that we we
intended to take away the ability for
them to enter into those power purchase
agreements if they make sense I mean
wouldn't they still have to go in front
of the Pu and everything and and
obviously it's the legislative
prerogative but I if I remember
correctly there was a a uh up until
whatever the date is June 30th 2025 uh
the utilities could put out the RFP and
then they had uh year to bring that
forward to the commission so I think
there was another date of whatever
2026 um I I I'm not commenting on on
that other than to say at the time it
was intended to be a limited
Authority thank you commissioner
appreciate those that clarification for
us I'd also like to point out that this
amendment does not change the uh 2
million megawatt hour or 20% load
restriction that it's already in statute
as a result of centerel 54 so those
limits would still apply even to the
advanced nuclear resources that are
allowed under this legislation
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman uh I like this a whole lot
better than the original Bill much much
better I thank you for being open to
changing it uh there is a typo on line
10 where it says RSA 374 G11 that should
be 374 f11 there is no 374
G11 and and this text is
okay did you find another
typo uh it's a question of whether it's
a typo or not so um the first date is
June 30 2025 to to request an RFP and
then an agreement can be made in June 30
2026 so one year later but then there's
no agreement with the June 30th 2035
shouldn't the in line 24 shouldn't that
be June 30th
RFP good question there you go
I'm going to circle
there so how would you feel about uh
adopting this amendment and this
legislation and then doing a floor
typos representative
reels thank you Mr chairman still um I
I'd be good with it I think U but I had
another substantive question really um
line 21 a new
Clause um the department shall be
authorized to issue requests for
proposals I assume that's our department
of energy and I'm Just Fur my brow at
that because is that it seems like I
have is that a new role for the State
Department of energy to be issuing an
RFP on be was that on behalf of of the
state's utilities could you
elaborate yes when I had a discussion
with the Department about this amendment
they requested that I add that language
and I don't really remember exactly why
that if I could you know is that
something that's happened before in New
Hampshire seems like a big new thing
we'll find in just a
second commissioner thank you Mr
chairman uh I'm joined by David shulock
our general counsel um and and I would
say you know when we we discussed with
representative V we did we did discuss
that it might be something you want to
do it's it it really is up to the
legislature whether or not you want to
include it the reason the department was
not included as uh sort of the issuer of
the rfps and Senate Bill 54 was due in
large part to sort of the uh the time
sensitive nature as as I alluded to
before that folks wanted to move
something forward quickly and that at
the time the department did not
necessarily have the um expertise or or
necess you know the time to go through
whatever Contracting process we would
have to do to get the expertise on board
in the time frame that I think folks
were imagining uh it wasn't it wasn't
because the department might not be an
appropriate uh entity to put out an RFP
uh especially on something like this
where we really have a state public
policy goal that this that legislature
would be putting into uh effect um I
think given the longer time frame that
was contemplated here I think out to
2035 that is something that it you know
if we were to participate to put out an
RFP we would be able to um get the next
the necessary expertise on board so it's
whether or not you want the department
to do it uh there are arguments um in in
favor and and and maybe against but uh
we are comfortable with that Authority
so this language would authorize the
Department to issue rfps but would not
require the department to is issue rfps
correct I'll let David weigh and I'm
sorry I still haven't seen the amendment
I think that's correct but you might
want to add in the statute that we are
issuing the RFP on behalf of the
utilities
yeah
okay may representative rolds thank you
Mr
articulate some of the
potential benefits of having the state
act in this way on behalf of the state's
utilities as opposed to having the
utilities do it for themselves one or
more absolutely it's a good question I
think and it's one I want to just be
careful I'm not um in in no way
disparaging the utilities I think you
know they would do it fabulously I think
there's you could make an argument that
this the department as a new neutral
sort of uh party here would not
necessarily have any conflict uh towards
a particular resource um or or you know
uh we would we would be able to
recognize that the Pol this was a policy
direction from the legislature you know
you could say that perhaps a utility
might say the juice isn't worth the
squeeze for them if they're not if
they're not necessarily going to benefit
from it why would they go through the
process of putting out an RFP the the
department might more inclined to do
that um you know recognizing the
direction from the legislature I don't
know if David has anything to add to
that I think that summarizes
it okay representative Harrington has a
question first I want to thank
representative Reynolds for pointing
this part out I had missed it and I just
trying to read this over to me this is a
major major change in policy uh where
smells like Massachusetts in the room
all of a sudden
the department is authorized to issue
requests for proposals I I don't even
know what that means so the Department's
going to go out and say we want you to
supply us uh 500 megawatt or 200
megawatts of something and then we're
going to turn around to the utilities
and say you must buy this I mean if you
don't have the authority to enforce the
contract on the utility then who's going
to submit something to you because you
be no different than if I went out and
said you must Supply utility uh money I
I think this is a huge policy change
should not be addressed in an amendment
like this and I really don't want the
department going out and issuing
requests for proposals because the only
reason that would mean anything is if
then going to turn around to the utility
and say now we've got a proposal you're
buying it and that sets up a huge
conflict then because that could go to
the Pu and the Pu could turn around and
say we're not approving the contract
because it's not in the best interest of
the rate payers it's too expensive
whatever so this is a real rabbit hole
with crawling down on this one sentence
there so I I can't go along with this Mr
chairman do you mind if I just give some
thoughts on that um you know uh from our
perspective it is up to the legislature
whether or not you want to do this you
know Senate Bill 54 was an expansion of
power purchase agreement Authority uh
that was something legislature undertook
so if the legislature wants to continue
that that's within your purview we will
do what we are directed to do by the
legislature I'll I'll let David talk a
little bit about um what might be
necessary if you wanted to pursue this
for us to make sure that those contracts
are uh
enforced so under under this Paradigm uh
all of those contracts would go to the
Public Utilities Commission for review
that's part of that original statute so
uh the department would only be issuing
the RFP to move things along right um it
might be useful to have some additional
language and statute about utility
responsibility to purchase
I can't make that language up here as
we're speaking right uh but that that
might be useful um you know that there
is nothing at this point um and this
language would would get us a little
closer to it for anr for the Department
to do things like issue um requests for
information rather than requests for
proposals
so what would it take who is interested
in building anr in New Hampshire for us
to purchase right so so that we could
start looking at what that market looks
like for New Hampshire and um find out
if there are companies interested in
coming here to to do things like that um
that's not I don't think that's required
in the language for us to do it uh but
this would get us a step closer to
it so to that to that point should the
language say the department shall be
authorized to
issue requests for
proposals you could I don't think it's
necessary but you could okay
representative
Harrington I still have a major concern
because what it doesn't address is the
utility it says the department shall be
authorized to Issue request for
proposals now so they get the proposal
and they then authorized to go go to the
utilities and say you will accept this
proposal and you will sign a PPA and and
then you'll submit that whatever that uh
contract is to the Pu or can the
utilities just simply say we would have
signed that if we thought it was a good
idea we don't need you to tell us how to
go out and negotiate contracts for
electric supply because we've been doing
that for the last uh 15 years whatever
and we have a lot of experts at that
we're not going to do it so I don't know
where this leaves us it's like it's like
stopping so I I think you have
exposed a Hole uh in in that Paradigm if
if we're going to be doing the RFP and
it would be useful to have additional
language along those lines when I said
on behalf of the utilities um that got
us part of the way there and you know if
I'm looking at we're we're probably not
going to do that for renewable since the
DAT is passed but for anr you know we
would still have 10 years to to work on
that process
so representative
Kaplan yeah I I don't really want to
address the debate over whether the
department should be the one issuing the
rfps or not I think that's an
interesting discussion we already you I
will just add that we already have state
mandated procurement of energy uh in one
form or another um but what I do want to
address is the the uh the date issue
about the you know the original language
of Senate bill whatever it was 54 um I
think that we ought to be expanding this
uh this new program to all forms of
energy because right now it's anr and
that's you know that's trendy and we
like it but 10 years from now it could
be something else so why are we just
limiting it to anr we should be opening
it up again by removing that original
language about June 30th 2025 I think
that's
silly would the department object to
we would probably have concerns with a
full expansion of power purchase
agreements um you know we we would have
to talk about it there was a bill uh
that was introduced uh in the Senate and
that that is looks like it's coming over
Senate bill I think 112 um that that
talked about power purchase agreements
you know we did have concerns related to
um to rapair impacts and administrative
uh impacts uh I'm not prepared to talk
uh to give you a full position on on
expanding the date the date was an
important guard rail that we had um
worked on a couple years ago and to this
to this time still still want to
maintain
that all right let's Reserve that
discussion for Senate Bill 112 when it
gets
here all right let's representative
Corman so uh it's too bad the Patriots
are not playing this week because I find
myself agreeing with representative
Harrington uh for all the reasons he
stated and and also I just feel like I
think the utilities are very capable of
putting out their own
rfps all right representative F and
thank you chair um since you're we're
rewriting it on line five page one you
said you took this from another source I
didn't write down where but on line six
I noticed a dash for describing sodium
cold is missing that might or might not
quotes sorry what are you referring to
specifically
hyphen if you want get
that oh sodium cool you think should be
hyphen Ed is that what you're saying
you all the other ones are and you said
you took that from another um just
wonder if the quote is
exact
okay yeah I get it I get it okay well
I'm looks like I'm going to walk over
and and ask for an amendment anyway
another an amendment change so um I can
I can do that all right let's uh let's
move on because it's getting late
um I think we're going to have to defer
since there is no Amendment a discussion
of HB 535 until the executive
session so we've discussed all the
Amendments that we're going to have in
the executive session so why don't we
break now for lunch and return here at
1:15 to begin the executive session so I
e
okay it being 117 we are going to resume
our activity for the
day and we are going to have executive
sessions on five different
bills HB 221 relative to assessment of
cost effectiveness of the system
benefits charge HB 672 to allow offgrid
electricity providers in New Hampshire
HB 710 enabling Electric utilities to
own offer own operate and offer Advanced
nuclear
resources HB 535 FN relative to defining
the role of the Public Utilities
Commission HB 599 establishing a
committee to examine weather in
weatherization initiatives for homes in
New Hampshire and HR are
15 urging New Hampshire's Congressional
representatives to advocate for a change
in the Federal Energy
Regulatory commission's policies and
that's six bills not
five and you are
correct I was just noticing that as I
was reading through this I realized that
HB 599 wasn't on my original Mr chair um
resolution yes five bills and one
resolution technically that is that is
correct
yeah so anyway that's what we're doing
and uh so we're now we're going to
start old so I'm going to open an
executive session on House Bill
221 relative to assessment of cost
effectiveness of the system benefits
charge and I recognize representative
Harrington for a motion uh Mr chairman I
move to uh
pass the bill as originally presented
ought to pass the unamended version
chair recognizes representative
Summers I second that motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill
221 representative Harrington do you
want to uh defend your motion uh well I
I just think uh we've had plenty of
discussion on this this morning I I
still think it gives the uh ability for
the Pu to go back after a period of time
to look at um if there would need to be
any changes to the way the system
benefits are measured and it only does
so with a complete adjudicative process
and they have to have that open so all
parties would be uh present
in yesterday was
Monday yeah yeah yes I need them by 7
o'clock tomorrow morning because I have
to have them turned in by noon tomorrow
okay okay okay thank
you all right so we have closed the
221 so now I'm going to open an exec
session on House
Bill
672 FN to allow for off-grid electricity
providers in New Hampshire and I am
going to move ought to
0627 H and I recognize representative
Thomas I
second moved and seconded that we adopt
a motion of octop pass as amended
by
H we had an extensive discussion about
this bill this morning we went over the
changes that the amendment makes to the
bill and I think everyone has a thorough
understanding of the bill at this point
in time so I would look for your support
for passing this amendment and this bill
further
discussion representative Corman thank
you Mr
chairman I feel a little awkward here
because I actually co-sponsored the bill
but I'm going to be voting against it
because from what I learned in testimony
and and and what I've come to realize in
in my own thoughts and discussion is
that I'm I'm I'm concerned here about
safety I'm concerned about someone
really just unregulated running their
own power plant um and just all the
Mayhem that may ensue
so just as I've learned about it and
thought about it I decided to vote
against it even though I was a
co-sponsor
further discussion representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman um after
looking at it and discussing the the
bill here with especially with the
amendment where it makes them exempt
from RSA title 34 and then looking to
find that RSA 34 is just basically how
the state and the bureaucracy grabs
revenue from the electrical companies
therefore the reason why they'd want RSA
34 in place so they can get their hands
on the money for it um I am voting for
this
bill further
discussion representative Thomas um
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair um it
was stated that this bill um leaves the
solving of problems to innovators um my
concern about that is that it also open
opens up a situation of the Wild Wild
West in New Hampshire so I will also be
voting against this
bill further
discussion see uh representative Swanson
thank you Mr chair I believe that uh
there are this this bill opens up too
many opportunities for unintended
consequences and is not thoroughly
vetted as far as what they might be so
I'm against this further
discussion representative parshall thank
you chair um my concern U is that we are
putting our thumb on on uh small nuclear
reactors which could be a very viable
solution but I think that they we need
to let the market play out on this so
I'm I'm going to keep probably going to
discussion all right seeing none I'm
going to ask the clerk to call the role
first on the adoption of the
amendment
h v sh Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan
yes representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
no representative Corman
no representative rold
yes representative La roelle yes
representative Swanson no chairman Vose
yes okay five one two three four five
six 7 8 9 10 11 12 to
5 I a voted 12 to five the amendment is
adopted now I'll ask the clerk to call
the role on the question of ought to
down that's what I
said Alo who made the motion yeah we
need
yeah who who's done these
motions representative N I forgot to get
a second I second the motion Mr
chair representative not second the
motion of ought to pass is amended and
you made the primary
right and now the clerk can call the
amended Vice chair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative Bernardi
yes representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan
yes representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
no representative Corman no
representative rolds yes representative
La relle yes representative Swanson
by a vote of 12 to5 the committee adopts
the motion about to pass as amended on
House Bill 672 I will write the majority
um report will there be a Minority
Report yes Wendy Thomas and Wendy Thomas
will write The Minority Report by 7 a.m.
okay we'll close the executive session
now on House Bill
672 we are still waiting for an
amendment on House Bill
710 just to fill everybody in so I check
yet doesn't appear to be here yet just
to uh let everybody know I corrected
those three
typos and eliminated the sentence that
allows the department of energy to
submit requests for proposals that
seemed to be a fairly significant policy
change that wasn't made clear to me when
I I made the produced the original
Amendment so the new Amendment deletes
that sentence
altogether and we'll have that at some
point I don't don't know exactly when so
hr15 I'll open an exec session on that
and I'll can on representative
Harrington for a motion on the bill and
an amendment oops I don't have the
amendment number in front of me
so let me just
grab okay I move to amend the bill with
Amendment
0679 which basically replaces the uh
first part of the bill and then I move
ought to pass on the
amendment so you move ought to pass on
hr15 as amended by
20256 79h correct correct correct okay
chair recognizes
representative Matson I second it moved
and seconded that we
adopt hr15 as amended by Amendment
0679 H representative
Harrington well I don't think we need
too much more discussion on this it
basically says that in a nutshell the uh
utility projects that are done for
Distribution Systems in New hampsh sure
are scrutinized by the Pu and the
utility has the obligation of proving
their costs just and reasonable in order
to collect them on the other hand on the
federal level if a transmission project
which could be 10 20 50 times more
expensive uh FK has a policy of
presumption of prudency which they say
whatever cost is submitted by the
transmission company are assumed to be
just and reasonable unless someone else
proves otherwise this would ask uh
Congressional members down
uh obviously in Washington to do
whatever they could to change this firk
policy okay thank you I think the U
language on lines three through five
that spells
out that current FK policy is to accept
new and upgraded transmission
costs via a presumption of prudence
without a detailed review of individ
individual project cost is a a good
addition to this amendment I think that
spells out exactly why we are concerned
about this issue so thank you
representative McGee for um putting that
together any further
discussion representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um this is
going to come as a shock to everyone I
think but um I agree with this um
resolution with the except of the final
line with the state librarian I just
think it's redundant but it's not enough
for me to vote against
it further
discussion representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair I like
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
0679 no
Vice shair Thomas yes representative n
yes representative Harrington
yes representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee yes representative
parall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas lendy Thomas yes
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes representative Rochelle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman
Vose yes
Zero by a vote of 17 to zero the
committee adopts the
amendment Mr chair represent yes
representative Harrington uh I would not
like this put on the consent calendar
because I would like to bring it up on
the floor of the house so that
everyone's aware of it we haven't got
that far yet okay that's up okay we're
not there yet but but I hear
you so now we need a motion from
representative Harrington to adopt the
motion of ought to pass as amended I
move ought to pass as Amendment amended
chair recognizes representative
nter I second the motion moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of to
pass as amended on
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk as soon as he is ready to call the
role on the question AER Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes rep representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall yes
representative Kaplan yes representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas yes repres
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes
representative La relle yes
representative Swanson yes did I
miss any Kaplan okay all right
representative
Swanson yes chairman Vose yes 17 z i a
vote of 17 to zero the committee adopts
hr15 representative Harrington will
write the committee
report but the bill will not go on the
consent calendar so
that representative Harrington if he can
persuade the speaker and the clerk can
speak on the bill on the
floor so with that we'll close the
15 representative parshall yes I'm sorry
Dr the flow here but um how do you keep
a bill I mean this is informative to me
I've never seen a bill pass that should
be on consent that is purposely not
going to be on consent would it help if
we had 10 people to pull it off consent
no okay okay you can just say please
don't put on consent that's good enough
y it's our decision whether to put it on
consent or not not the clerk's decision
it's our decision so if we say no
consent then it doesn't go on consent
that's good to know I never do that
thank
you yes representative n so another
example of something not going on
consent would be like um a bill to name
a bridge in a town after someone that
would the whole committee votes for it
and it's not on consent because they
want to talk about it I've seen that
before thank you so much you're
welcome right you'll recall that on
occasion there's someone in the gallery
that's affected by a bill and so uh even
though it might be unanimous that the
house adopts the bill you still want to
talk about it so you can recognize the
gallery all right so moving along we
still don't have the amendment for House
Bill 710 yet that last
check so we will now move
to House Bill
535 relative to defining the role of the
Public Utilities Commission and I will
recognize representative
Bernardi move itl chair recognizes
representative schneller second moved
and seconded that we adopt the motion of
itl on House Bill
535 chair recognizes representative
Bernardi so the the predominant reason
for iing this is because uh it
requires uh any um agreement that is
reached between the parties cannot be
reviewed or would not be reviewed by the
Pu so essentially takes the Pu out of
the out of the function of that that is
their job to review the review these
appropriate further comment
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman the testimony we heard
yesterday from the Pu said
that they can only base on the evidence
that they're presented at hearings
that's why they wanted to make sure that
the doe was at at
hearings
and given that it seems that if all the
evidence they're
getting from the parties agrees about a
settlement they're not going to get any
other evidence so they're going to end
up concluding that anyway so I don't see
why there's a problem with this if all
the parties agree and all the evidence
presented to the puc says we're we're in
agreement on this what would the Pu have
to go on that was presented to the
contrary other than what the bill says
would be which is if something is
law well to answer your question it
could allow one of the regulated
utilities to bypass pu review if they
just agree to a
settlement then whatever they have
proposed or whatever is proposed in the
settlement
agreement according to this stat
according to this bill would have to be
adopted by the Pu so it would allow the
utilities to bypass pu review in that
case and they could cleverly manipulate
the settlement process to create
settlements that favor them without
having any review by the Pu so I think
this is a very dangerous piece of
legislation to pass uh in its current
form uh nobody wanted this piece of
legislation nobody testified in favor of
it except the consumer Advocate and I I
just think this is a
dangerous um piece of legislation there
is there's no confusion or uncertainty
about the respective roles of the Pu and
doe in this regard and uh so I I just I
I agree with representative Bernardi
that this is a dangerous bill and we
shouldn't go forward with
it representative Corbin thank you
um well for one thing we heard nothing
but Discord yesterday between doe and
pu uh so I I don't think they're on the
same page about about who has what what
power uh and with regard to the
utilities being able to do things
unchecked I I would point out that in uh
page two section five um starting on
line 23 it says in any contested case
before the commission to which the
department of energy and the office of
the consumer Advocate are parties so
it's not just the utilities that would
be presenting something the the doe and
the consumer Advocate would have to
agree and you know the consumer Advocate
is not really noted for just going along
with the utilities so I I don't see a a
problem here about the utilities um
running a muck or anything like that I I
I think that uh you know we we have the
right checks here to make sure that we
have the right parties in the
agreement further discussion
representative
bernardy I just think the right checks
are in the adjudicative process that
occurs in front of the Pu so uh if
parties have largely agreed on an
approach they can present that approach
but the Pu gets to ask questions about
the data that's presented to them to
tease out if there's any underlying
issues and and if they just have to
accept an agreement as written that
opportunity is foreclosed
further discussion representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman um okay I I I'm
rereading the bill because I think it's
really important to see what it actually
says rather than just what we all think
it says and it it does seem to be a good
faith effort to try and
um try and Define areas where there has
been some difficulty uh or some question
as to who plays which role role so it it
makes an effort to parse those uh roles
but to representative Bernard's
Point part two line five page two says
the authority of the commission shall
consist of conducting contested
adjudicative proceedings within the
meaning of RSA 541 D a31 on matters
concerning the rates charges tariffs and
services provided by the public
utilities um as defined in RSA 362 colon
2 and others as specifically authorized
under this title and to adopt
administrative rules consistent with its
Authority as provided in this title they
are authorized to conduct adjudicative
proceedings which means asking questions
requiring evidence calling the utilities
and other stakeholders on the carpet to
answer the questions that they have so
this doesn't limit or eliminate any of
the authority of the Pu it merely tries
to clarify the places where there seems
to be difficulty in the process that has
been observed by the people who are over
there watching how things are operating
at this point um and the other bolded
sections I mean this is a a wholesale
rewriting right this is a I don't know
is this a new section the whole
thing looking to see where it starts
yeah I don't see what it's replacing
actually at the it's just adding a
paragraph to um to 3631 a section yeah
yeah
um so so the other bolded section on
page three line
two it shall further be the duty of the
Department of energy to petition the
commission for appropriate relief
through RSA 36541 to 44 RSA 374 col 41
or other appropriate action when the
department reasonably believes that a
public utility is failing to discharge
its obligation pursuant to this title I
thought the explanation in reference to
this bill yesterday was that when there
is an adjudicative proceeding where the
parties have all come to agreement in
front of um the Public Utilities
Commission that they should make a good
faith effort to let that go through true
unless they have some specific reason
you know because it is costly for
everyone to continue to convene and
convene and convene in front of a body
that isn't coming to a conclusion on
something where everyone else that's
involved is already um at a settlement
because they they usually are um on
opposing
sides representative
Bernardi so the key word that you read I
think was the third or fourth word in in
your initial reading was
contested the issue here is if there's
an agreement that's been signed and
everybody signs off on it it isn't
contested and therefore all those
proceedings are not on the table what
proceeding ask
questions no it doesn't say uh that you
read the word contested if it is
contested then you can do all those
things the the the point of this bill
was it opens up the opportunity for
behind this the
puc's purview agreeing on a uh a a an
approach and there's no contest
therefore just rubber stamp it and move
on okay further discussion
representative
Harrington yeah my major problem with
this is first of all I'm not even quite
sure if it's legal um what you're having
here is a a group of parties presenting
something to the adjudicative body
saying that excuse me that we all agree
this is the way this uh issue should be
resolved and you're saying the
adjudicative body has no um ability to
do anything other than to say well
that's a legal um solution so therefore
we must approve it it would be sort of
like to put an analogy the uh in the
courts where the district attorney and
the defense attorney reach some kind of
an agreement on a plea bargain and they
go to the judge and the judge says you
want to let this person out he's
murdered two people with only five years
no I'm not approving the plea bargain if
we put this into effect the judge would
have absolutely no authority to do it
he'd have to say well whatever you guys
agree to it's not illegal so you can let
the guy get out with one day in jail if
you want to but I don't have no
authority to overturn it you you don't
take that Authority away from the Pu and
I can tell you as a former pu
commissioner if someone brought me a a
deal like that and said here it is we've
all agreed with it I would want to
review the deal I want to ask questions
about the deal and if I didn't think it
was the right thing to do I wouldn't
sign it regardless of the law you could
take kick me off the commission but I'm
not signing a deal that I think is wrong
and I don't think it's right to impose
that on any pu commissioner they should
have the ability to adjudicate something
in front of them obviously take a strong
recommendation if all parties are
involved but all parties involved don't
have the authority and the
responsibility of the Pu to set
policy further comment representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman well I don't
I don't agree with the
interpretation uh
that this language would
be tying the hands of the Pu so
strictly uh as representative her just
described rather what I I what I feel is
that in light of the testimony we heard
yesterday that passing this bill would
be sending a an important
message well it would be making an
important law which would be carrying an
important message and making a statement
that the legislature wants the Pu to
abide by the division of
responsibilities that were put in place
several years ago between
an administrative
body and the policymaking body of the
Department of energy we've heard and
we've seen that the Pu is continually
straying out of its Lane and attempting
to insert itself re reinsert itself uh
into the policymaking decisions by you
know refusing to approve settlements I
mean the consumer Advocates said the
ratemaking process is broken
that's pretty strong
stuff um so I I think that this is an
essential statement by the
legislature it was a strong statement by
the OCA but it wasn't necessarily a
correct
statement further discussion
representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair I believe
that there is evidence of existing
friction uh with the doe and the Pu and
and I do believe that this does make a
step toward improving clarification or
definition of the processes and roles
and responsibilities and does not open
the door for
abuse thank
you why take that chance further
discussion representative McGee thank
you Mr chair so um again looking to the
bill and on a number of different lines
I noticed that under various sections of
365 the section on inspections on
authority to inspect um under
the I guess the extent of power to amend
the there were a number of places I read
the original 80 pages that constituted
the department of energy when we didn't
have a department of energy for several
years and it struck me at the time
because I had done organizational
development in my career that there was
a real lack of clarity about who was
doing what and that it could cause
problems in the future and I actually
mentioned it I remember at the time to
the consumer Advocate who was you know
going along and saying this is going to
be great and I'm like yeah but I don't I
think this is really blurry this bill
attempts to actually clarify what the
doe should be um responding to and
answering so it actually goes you know
to the place of trying to
say uh
this is how it actually works in in in
operation um between the two now that we
have two functioning uh departments to
look to look at in terms of how they're
operating so it it goes to
the uh lengths of trying to eliminate
the Public Utilities Commission in
places where it says Department of
energy and Public Utilities Commission
so it it confuses the fact of who's
doing what and that is perhaps why the
public utilities commission is concerned
that it needs to do some of the things
that it doesn't need to do anymore
because we now have a department of
energy which we didn't have for several
years before
then so I think it's I think it's
actually a good clarification and I
don't see any danger here um in the Pu
not being able
to perform all of the things that they
do currently as an adjudicator of these
cases I I do take the point that if if
it's an uncontested case
um you know the concern is well if
everybody here agrees what if I don't
agree and it I think that the Public
Utilities Commission is not a party to
the agreement right they are the
adjudicator to see is it a reasonable
thing so they still get to get all of
what they need answered but if they're
coming to a different conclusion than
everyone whose party I would question
how that how that
occurs what are they what are they
receiving for information that isn't um
part of the
adjudication well you have to remember
the puc has about six or seven lawyers
on their staff and they
constantly pour through and comb through
the
rsas to make sure that every decision
they make conforms with state
law representative Corman thank you so
far all the objections I've heard I
think are to section five of the bill
are there objections to parts of the
five I personally object the entire bill
because nobody asked for it except the
OCA there's
no you know demonstrated reason why we
need this bill that's that's my main
issue with this bill especially given
the fact that it gives it ties to people
pu's hands with regards to settlement
agreements I just don't think that's a
good idea and I don't think we should
move forward with the bill it seems to
me that what we heard yesterday morning
was good evidence that we need this bill
there's this turf war between doe and
the Pu and this bill tries to
clarify the divisions between the Pu and
the
doe and the reason I asked about any
objections other than section five I
mean I would consider an amendment that
removes that section and the supporting
text and the findings just if for no
other reason than to clarify the
pu seems to me that statute already def
defines the difference between the
two any further discussion seeing none
I'd ask the clerk to call the role in
VI sh Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative
Harrington yes representative Bernardi
yes representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee no representative
parshall oh representative Kaplan no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La Rochelle no
representative Swanson no chairman Vose
yes
98 so by a vote of 9 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of itl on House Bill
535 representative Bernardi will write
the majority report will there be a
Minority Report yes that'll be
representative Corman representative
Corman will write The Minority
Report by 7 am tomorrow
morning all right so we're done with
House Bill
and I am still tracking down the
amendment Amendment on House
so while we continue to wait for this
bill to this amendment to show up we'll
open a public I mean an executive
session on House Bill
599 establishing a committee to examine
weatherization initiatives for homes in
New Hampshire and I will make a motion
of itl for this bill and recognize
representative Vice chair Thomas second
moved in seconded that we itl this bill
the reason I make this motion is because
weatherization is a well understood
topic we
have in the 11 years I've been in the
legislature we've seen probably six or
seven bills similar to this one and they
never go anywhere because the Department
of energy has good command of the
weatherization programs that exist in
the state as to the utilities with New
Hampshire saves and I don't see anything
to be gained by doing another study
committee report on a topic that's
already well understood so for that
reason I think we should just itl this
bill further comments representative
Harrington yeah a couple of quick things
I mean one thing is sort of like what I
consider almost a silly line in the Bill
about the someone's supposed to be able
to get assess the uh status of every
house in New Hampshire as far as how
well it's insulated I mean I don't know
who's going to do that or how that's
going to be done certainly anyone on
this commission better spend on and
spend 247 working on it because it'll
take them that long for months in order
to come up with that but secondly this
isn't necessary I mean just think about
it every month you get your electric
bill you open it up what do you get in
there New Hampshire saves go here here's
the website you want a free energy audit
here's where you go we've got a good
program it's working we don't need
another study committee to conclude that
we've got a good program and it's
working representative
Kaplan yeah I will be uh opposing the
itl motion um I agree the New Hampshire
saves is an excellent program um but we
really do not have an understanding of
the housing stock overall in the state
and we really need to assess the Need
For What ization on an overall basis and
not wait for people to approach New
Hampshire saves on an individual level
to try to get what help they deserve we
have a housing crisis in this state and
and especially an affordability crisis
and that's been acknowledged by all all
parties including our governor and uh
it's a bottleneck on our state's
Economic Development we can't attract
young Working Families because we don't
have enough houses and the houses that
we do have are unaffordable part of the
reason they're unaffordable is because
they're not weatherized we don't have an
overall picture of the housing stock and
the need for such programs in our state
so I think it's strategic it's Forward
Thinking and it's uh it's an economic
necessity for us to have that
information so that we can craft
programs and improve uh the reach of
weatherization yes it's well understood
the benefits are very well understood
but what we don't understand is the need
for such programs in our state so that's
forward representative um yeah Thomas
Wendy Thomas thank you um
uh I agree with with everything
representative Kaplan just said the best
way that we can help our constituents
save energy money is through um adequate
insulation um and one of the things I
asked the prime sponsor about was um
would this include education and that is
the key thing um because it's not just
the people that get El
oh I beg your pardon um I it is not the
people that that get the bills it's it's
it's everyone and they need to
understand the importance of
weatherization and how it can help them
money okay representative McGee thank
you Mr current chairman you can't get
away from me I know you were hoping I
wouldn't put my hand up but I
so when we were having the hearing on
this bill um I mentioned to
representative Howard that um there is a
group that uh used to participate in the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board called
GDs um one of their principles Matt cisa
had reached out to me on this bill HB
599 and he said are you aware that we
have a monthly meeting that includes all
the stakeholders around weatherization
including contractors you know small
business owners um agencies and the
utilities and he said that the topics
that they are covering including what
kind of Workforce do we have to do
weatherization work in New Hampshire you
know the the the very things that this
bill contemplates he was he said you
know we could be a resource to these
folks if you constitute a committee on
this and so I don't think I you know
said a lot about it in the hearing or
you know made a very good case for it
but basically their interest was we
would love it if the legislature would
actually take a look at the housing
stock in New Hampshire we have a lot
that we could offer in terms of making
them understand better where we're at in
terms of penetration for making the
housing stock more um More Energy
Efficiency and again that lowers that
that creates negawatts that's what
Energy Efficiency does Nega what is the
energy you no longer use and the more of
that that we can build up the better A
system that we have in terms of
Independence representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chairman so uh
this argument about establishing a
committee is
another argument for a government
oversight of a industry that is
functioning
and to to me this is antithetical to the
entire concept of free enterprise if
there is a need and then there may be a
need for insulation weatherization
whatever that need is known by those who
experience it and they will use their
resources if they have them in advancing
dealing with that need we don't need a
government program to Define people's
needs
further
discussion representative
parial um at first I was in agreement
that we don't need another committee but
upon hearing some of the espe in
particular um what representative uh Mia
has to say about resources that are
available in the community I think if we
want to improve our housing stock which
we IND desperate need of improving maybe
a fresh set of eyes maybe an order in a
case like this I will be voting for
Bill further discussion representative
reels thank you Mr chairman um while I
while I do agree with uh some of the
sentiments expressed
uh against the bill
um
I think that the what is what is asked
for by this bill what would happen under
this bill is a really small effort uh
with as near as I can tell the cost of
four people getting mileage
reimbursement to meet a few
times uh I think that the government
could play an important you know
convening role here
um and information gathering role more
than any anything
um yes about the existing resources
existing programs at our doe and our New
Hampshire saves but you know the New
Hampshire financing Authority has other
things uh it just could be an import a
valuable convening of
Minds um sort of assessing uh you know
the current reach current effectiveness
of of weatherization efforts and
identifying maybe some gaps and some
ways that things might be improved uh
improved uh use of those existing
resources so I think it's a small ask
and I would ask my my colleagues all of
us to to just uh I don't think there's a
lot of harm in supporting it and some
good things could come out of it thanks
okay Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chair um I you know weatherization as uh
some of my previous colleagues have
stated is a a well-known phenomenon it's
been studied over and over again I see
no read to to spend uh money and time uh
to study it again uh information is out
there uh this would be no more effective
in study than if we uh want to do a
study of why uh people shouldn't smoke
in restaurants I mean we all know what's
uh what's out there and the education
issue again it's on your electric bill
people know about it and if you're not
getting an electric bill you're not
paying for your power um and so I this
is just to me uh a good intention by uh
a person that was well intended but U
we've done it and so there for I will be
supporting the it
motion okay so seeing no further
comments I'd ask the clerk to call the
role on the question of the motion of
599 Vice Shar Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bernardi yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
yes representative schneller yes
representative McGee no Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan no
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman no Representative
rolds no representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman Vose
yes 98 by a vote of 9 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of itl on House Bill
59 99 I will write the majority report
will there be a Minority Report yes
Thomas representative Wendy Thomas will
write The Minority Report and have it to
me by 7
a.m. tomorrow okay with that we'll close
the exact session on House Bill
599 and now we're down to the last bill
which
is house bill 710 exec session I move
the
adoption of House Bill
710 with
Amendment 2025
H and I recognize Vice chair Thomas
second moved and seconded that
we adopt House Bill 710 as amended by
Amendment
H so there are four changes that this in
Amendment introduced three of them
are Corrections or or typos in line six
sodium cooled is now sodium Dash
cooled that's a
biggie and in
line
it's line 10 right the the uh RSA 374 G
was changed to F that was just a
typo and then on line 21 the date June
30th of 2035 was changed to
2036 and then the fourth change is the
line that was in the amendment that we
were looking at this morning that
allowed the department of energy to
authorize rfps that line has been
removed entirely since that was a
significant policy change that
um was probably outside the purview
of of
this piece of legislation so I remove
that and other than that the this
amendment is identical to the one we
just discussed this morning so I hope
you'll support this amendment I think
this is a good way to signal to the rest
of the country that New Hampshire is
open for business when it comes to
Advanced nuclear resources and
that while this there's no
guarantee that utilities will acquire
any power from Advanced nuclear
resources based on this bill at least
there's an opportunity to do so so this
is an enabling piece of legislation and
it uses an existing piece of legislation
which is well
understood hasn't been used so we heard
this morning from the doe but it could
be used and so I think it's a a good
opportunity for us as a state to signal
that the source of future electricity is
probably going to be nuclear in this
country the major source and I think New
Hampshire needs to be at the Forefront
of of States getting ready to adopt
nuclear energy so I hope you'll support
this amendment and this bill and I'll
entertain comments representative
reels thank you Mr chairman uh yes I I
appreciate your um changes to the to the
bill and I think it's a a good bill I
agree with what you said I I think a
good way for us to describe what we're
doing here is we're
essentially authorizing our New
Hampshire distribution utilities to be
uh to be the anchor tenant if you will
uh for a uh Advanced nuclear reactor to
be to be built here in the state and I
think it's uh it's very forward-looking
so Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair um Mr chair
along with this bill and the few others
that we passed through this committee
all involving uh the message that New
Hampshire
uh is open to nuclear technology uh I
think this um uh I think along with this
bill I think people will see that New
Hampshire is finally changing and wants
to look at the prospects of possible
nuclear energy in the state particularly
small scale so I applaud this amendment
I think this bill should be passed and I
think this kind of puts the crowning
achievement on the several bills that
we've heard this year that all address
the very same issue so I intend of
course to support it representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman and just
to uh kind of like um steal a line from
it representative
Harrington yeah thank you Mr chairman
and I'm sure many of you already know
this because you probably read nuclear
news and nuclear News Daily like I do
but um the um the battle is on across
the country to
for um uh different states so Texas is
going all in 100% on attracting nuclear
U the Ohio's done something there's
there's six or seven other states that
have either reversed their policy saying
that there's no they didn't want any
nuclear plants built and are now
actively encouraging them to be built so
I mean I'm not sure this is going to put
us in first in first place but if we
don't have something like this we'll be
totally out of the running so I think we
we need a bill like this representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman I'm just
going to repeat two things I've said
earlier uh something I said two three
weeks ago which is my late wife would be
shocked that I'm voting for nuclear but
I am voting for nuclear here and
something I said this morning which was
thanking you Mr chairman for being open
to suggestions as to how to make this
bill
better you're welcome representative
Kaplan yeah I'm I I'm afraid I'm going
to be the cloud on the nuclear parade
here I'm going to be voting against this
bill because I believe that the existing
legisl should have been amended along
with the Amendments that you that you
wisely did offer Mr chair and that is
that uh the date of you know the Sunset
date on the original Power purchase
agreement amendments should really be
extended because yes right now we're
looking at nuclear and then nuclear is
is something that we're going to welcome
into our state but 10 years from now it
could be geothermal it could be offshore
wind it could be a lot of different
things and I think you know we shouldn't
be limiting it to just
nuclear sounds like an opportunity for a
bill next year representative
parshall thank you I I don't think that
uh representative Corman will be alone I
will be voting against this bill as well
and a new concern of mine this is really
this considering this by allowing our
utilities to become involved with this
are are which we which is a monopoly
that this legislature has oversight over
and the state has oversight we're really
setting ourselves up to uh work against
the free market and have a government
intrusion into the free market uh it
does put the finger on the scale and I
am still very hesitant about
that representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um I I actually am in favor of
the bill um I I don't think it solves
all of the things that we maybe want to
address in terms of the language around
uh you know sunsetting the original uh
concept on distributed utilities
entering into PPA with other forms of
energy but what it does do is it removes
that rate payer risk that we were
concerned about when when the language
included owning and operating because if
we if we insist that our utilities buy
or operate then that puts the risk all
on the rate payer and those are those
are extremely expensive but this bill um
I think allows them to enter into a
power purchase agre greement with
someone which might incentivize them to
come and build uh that small scale uh
plant here and so I I think it it sends
the right signals but it um and I don't
think we're all agreed you know on this
but I think it sends the right signals
without being overly heavy-handed
because all it's doing is allowing them
to enter into those agreements it's not
insisting that it happens um so I I
actually appreciate the changes that
have been made to bring it to this point
and I think it's an example of us
working as a as a
committee representative
bernardy thank you Mr chair so uh I am
not a marketer by trade I worked in the
pharmaceutical industry doing drug
development for 40 years but the one
thing the marketers did teach me is if
you're going to start a business the
first thing you need is not a product
customers representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair having lived
in Nevada for a few years and the fights
dealt with the fights over what to do or
how to dispose of nuclear waste I do
have some reservations about this on the
other hand I believe that we can we will
have the Technologies and the ability to
deal with that when this becomes mature
so I am in favor of
this representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um during the
testimony for this bill we heard that
there was a great risk for cost
overruns um and that there was um a very
high risk of stranded costs um which
would leave our rate payers on the hook
to pay potentially for these projects
just wanted to remind people of that
one this is uh Amendment completely
eliminates all
that representative schneller thank you
Mr chair um to address something that
representative schneller has the floor
please to address something
representative Herrington mention that
there are other states we are not
without competition I would say that if
no competition no market and there is
clearly a market for small modular
reactors uh to power data centers and an
entire nuclear industry and tech
industry surrounding that so this
legislation in conjunction with some of
the other bills that this committee has
passed uh to Vice chairman Thomas's
comments I think uh really puts together
a fairly healthy portfolio to send a
message to the market that we are indeed
in business for both nuclear power and
as a means to power incremental
technology
businesses um so I will be supporting
this Bill thank you to your point and to
representative Bernard's point the
faster the market grows the more
quickly companies will evolve to satisfy
that market
need any further discussion
needed seeing none I'd ask the clerk to
call the role on the
amendment we didn't do that yet right no
yeah call the RO on the amendment
H Vier Thomas yes representative ner yes
representative Harrington yes
representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative parshall
yes representative Kaplan no on the
amendment representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas no representative
Corman yes representative rolds yes
representative La roelle yes
representative Swanson yes chairman Bose
yes
152 by a vote of 15-2 amendment 0716 H
is
adopted so I will now move ought to pass
as amended and recognize representative
by chair Thomas second moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of
ought to pass as amended by 0716 H House
Bill 710 any further discussion
needed seeing none I'd ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of the
motion of ought to pass as
amended Vice CH Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative Bernardi
yes representative PL yes yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
Representative parall no representative
Kaplan no representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas no representative Corman yes
representative rolds yes representative
La Rochelle yes representative Swanson
yes chairman Bose
yes uh 143 by a vote of 14-3 the
committee adopts the motion about to
pass on House Bill 710 I will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report yes I'll do the Minority Report
Mr chair representative Kaplan will
write The Minority Report and I need
morning and with that we'll close the
executive session on House Bill
710 and I will thank you all for your
hard and significant work here today we
uh accomplished quite a
bit but we're not done so next Monday
March
10th we will have in the morning a full
on 11 bills I believe the number is that
we still have outstanding and then in
the afternoon we will have an executive
session on those same 11
bills we have to do this all on one day
next week because Tuesday is town
meeting day and the speaker's office has
asked us not to schedule any meetings on
Tuesday and since we only have this room
for either Monday or Tuesday that pretty
much seals Our Fate to having to do all
this work on Monday of next week so come
prepared study uh the existing bills and
and um have your comments ready have any
amendments you want to make ready and
we'll go from there Vice chair Thomas uh
thank you Mr chair uh just a note on on
uh next Tuesday um there there may be
some committies elsewhere that may
conduct business it's not disallowed so
if you are speaking on another bill
perhaps be uh be aware of any committee
that might be meeting on Tuesday just in
case they are
we won't
be so the speaker is going to allow
other committees to meet dis
discouraged disc but not disallowed oh
it's discouraged but not disallowed sort
of like geoengineering I
guess okay we have to notify the federal
authorities
J all right anybody else have anything
before we call it a day
okay we're done thank you everyone I
would ask everybody to clear this room
because Republicans need to
caucus so thank you everybody see you